MAY NINTH TH MAYBE NOT SECOND
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING.
WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED TWO BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS MORNING SO WE'RE
HOPING PEOPLE WILL MAKE IT
QUICK.
.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME IT SO WELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA IS SITTING
AND FOR MISTER OBERNOLTE THIS
MORNING THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
MR.
NOTICING THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGAN AS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
IF WE.
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AND I GUESS HE'LL BE PRESENTING
ON AB TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH WILL
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN REQUIRES
HEALTH CARD HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS TO POST ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THEIR WEBSITES
INCLUDING THEIR ANNUAL BUDGETS.
THE OARD MEMBERS FINANCE
REPORTS GRANT POLICIES
RECIPIENTS OF GRANT FUNDING THIS
BILL ALSO FLESHES OUT THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
GRANT POLICIES TO ENSURE THE
DISTRICTS FULLY CONSIDER THEIR
GUIDELINES FOR AWARDING GRANTS
AND TO MAKE THOSE GUIDELINES
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. THE AB
TWENTY NINETEEN HAS NO
OPPOSITION IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLIC
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
BEACH CITIES HELP DISTRICT.
COSTS ARE MINOR AND NOT LIKELY
TO BE SUBMITTED FOR
REIMBURSEMENT THROUGH THE STATE
MANDATE PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I THINK YOU'RE THEIR SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
BY KEEPING PEOPLE HERE ON BEHALF
OF BEACH CITIES HEALTH DISTRICT
AND I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON AMENDMENTS OR
IN STRONG SUPPORT THINK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
FROM FINANCE.
CHRIS FERGUSON PLANNING IT'S NO
FILE ON THIS.
I THINK MISTER BURKE HAS A
QUESTION ARMED.
THERE IS A PROVISION IN THIS
REGARD HOUSING ZACHAREK.
THERE WAS A.
A BILL LAST YEAR THAT HAD
HOUSING PART OF THIS NAY BACK
DOWN A LITTLE BIT ON THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GO FORWARD ON
THAT AND FUTURE. BUT WE AT THIS
BILLS PARTICULARLY JUST TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE TRANSPARENCY WITH
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT OKAY SAID
NOTHING ABOUT HOUSING. THAT'S IS
IT JUST TO MAKE SURE OF
TRANSPARENCY GOOD THANK YOU.
WHICH I CLOSE
EYES RESPECT ESCRIBA. WILL TAKE
THAT UP SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MISTER GRAYSON.
TO GRAYSON WILL BE PRESENTING ON
A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY IT ENJOYS
A TO PASS RECOMMENDATION ASSUME
IS WE GET A QUORUM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY PROVIDES A
VERY LIMITED EXEMPTION FOR
SPECIFIC PHILIP FEDERAL MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND THE BASE
REALIGNMENT AND CLOSURE WHICH IS
BRAK TRANSFER AND REDEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO
ONE OF THESE OF FORMER BASIS THE
CONCORD NAVAL WEAPONS STATION.
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY WOULD WOULD
WOULD ENABLE THE CITY OF CONCORD
TO COMPLETE THE FEDERAL TRANSFER
PROCESS AS PART OF THE CITY'S
REUSE PROJECT THE GREAT THING
ABOUT THIS BILL. IT WILL
ACTUALLY SAVE THE STATE MONEY BY
REMOVING THE NEED FOR COSTLY
STAFF REPORTS AT THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO REVIEW THIS
TRANSFER SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
WHICH ELECT CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK I WILL TAKE THAT UP SINCE WE
GET A QUORUM THINK AS YOUR
GRAYSON TAKE.
SINCE ARE NOW MEMBERS WAITING
THE AUDIENCE WERE GOING TO GO TO
COMMITTEE MEMBER MISTER QUIRK IS
GONNA HE'S GOT TO BILLS TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWENTY.
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB TWENTY TWENTY.
ALLOW FOR CANNABIS EVENTS TO BE
HELD AT ANY VENUE EXPRESSLY
APPROVED BY LOCAL JURISDICTION.
OUR CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THE
SPECIAL EVENTS TO BE HELD ON
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS ARE DISTRICT.
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION VENUES
COST TO THIS BILL ARE MINOR
NAMES ARE WILLING AB TWENTY
TWENTY CURRENTLY HAS NO
OPPOSITION.
HERE TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS IS
NICOLO DELUCA ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF OF.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE KLA
TO LOOKING HERE WE HAVE THE CITY
OF OAKLAND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WE SEE THIS AS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO GENERATE REVENUE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
LOOKS GOOD MORNING CARA ALSO BE
HAVE THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
HEY GOOD MORNING KIDDING APE ON
BEHALF OF WE DROP CANNABIS
DELIVERY IN THE LONG BEACH
COLLECTED ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING PAUL HAS VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS ARE
PRESENTING IS ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
KNOW FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO AND.
WRAP UP MISTER QUICK IRATE WILL
TAKE THAT UP WHEN THERE IS A
QUORUM YOUR NEXT BILL IS AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT IT ALSO
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
OUR THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
A. B.. TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT
WOULD ALLOW ADVISORY COMMITTEES.
TO ME VIA TELECONFERENCE
PROVIDED THEY MEET CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS THESE INCLUDE
ADOPTING GUIDELINES POSTING ONE
PHYSICAL LOCATION. FOR THERE IS
A QUORUM THAT WILL BE PRESIDENT.
AND INFORMATION ON HOW THE
PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE.
ADVISORY COMMITTEES ARE MOSTLY
OPERATED BY UNPAID VOLUNTEERS
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE OR
COUNTRY.
THEY PROVIDE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
IN A VARIETY OF SUBJECTS THEY
ARE UNPAID AND HAVE NO DECISION
MAKING AUTHORITY.
THERE'S ONLY ONE TIME COST
PRESSURE WITH SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING SAVINGS ACROSS ADVISORY
BODIES DUE TO REDUCED NEED FOR
TRAVELING USE OF CELEBES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISS HER COMING TO
HOLD FOR JUST A SECOND SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM IF THAT'S
ALRIGHT YES.
MEMSIC SHAKY READ THE ROLE.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER PRESIDENT.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROKE.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CHECK OUT.
EGGMAN.
FONG.
FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER GARCIA. IS
AARON. FLORA.
QUIRK.
HERE RIAS.
THANK YOU WITH THAT.
.
ESTABLISHES A QUORUM THIS ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I SEE IN MOTION BY MISTER
BIGELOW IN A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO.
.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER QUICK THAT GETS
OUT ON IN A ROLL CALL.
WE'RE GONNA WAIT ON THE OTHER
BILLS INTO WE HAVE.
SOME MORE FOLKS HERE.
.
MR CHILLED.
SEC YOUR NEXT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M HERE
TO PRESENT ON AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN.
WHICH WOULD PROTECT TENANTS
FROM BEING EVICTED OR OTHERWISE
PENALIZED FOR CALLING EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE AS NOTED IN THIS
COMMITTEE NOW SAYS THE BILL HAS
NEGLIGIBLE STATE COSTS IF ANY.
PASSED OUT OF JUDICIARY WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES IN RESPECT WE ASK YOUR
IBOOK.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
I HATE.
PAUL LANSBURY LOVINGLY LEGALLY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU
SPEAKERS THAN IS EVERY STONE
SUPPORT. I'D FOLKS NIGHTS WE'RE
GONNA GET A QUICK TODAY SO LET'S
BE READY RENOWNED MORE NUMBER
HAVE BATES HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FILE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO.
AND A SECOND BY MISTER QUIRK
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. OF ASK
YOUR SUPPORT AND THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
CHIP THANK YOU
.
ALRIGHT I'M WE HAVE NOW AUTHORS
WAITING.
SO.
SOMEBODY SEES VESTED BE GREAT IF
WE ANOTHER DOWN HERE.
WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND TWO
BILLS WILL GO AHEAD AND.
.
KNOW THAT CONSENT CALENDAR.
MISTER BIGELOW MOVES AGAIN SEN
MISTER QUICK SECOND SAT IF WE
CAN.
READ THROUGH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MADAM SECRETARY.
SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN NINETY
NINETEEN THIRTY NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. TWENTY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE UP TO
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN. TWENTY ONE
FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TO
FORTY EIGHT TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
TWO. TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX
TWENTY THREE NINETY SIX TWENTY
FOUR THAT BEEN TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
SIX TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT.
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX TEN TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX EIGHT FIVE. TWENTY
SIX NINETY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR THREE SEVEN FIFTY THREE
TWENTY SEVEN FOOT SIXTY NINE
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY THREE.
TWENTY EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY NINE TWENTY NINE TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE TWENTY NINE.
TWENTY NINE FORTY ONE TWENTY
NINE SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY THREE TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
SIX TWENTY NINE NINETY FOUR.
THIRTY TWELVE THIRTY THIRTY TWO
TWENTY THIRTY ONE TWENTY SIX
THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE THIRTY
ONE SIXTY EIGHT. THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY THREE THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE NINETY TWO
THIRTY TO FIFTY ONE THIRTY TO
THE TO THE TO. THIRTY TO FIFTY
FIVE THIRTY TO FIFTY EIGHT AND
THIRTY TO SIXTY.
THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION A
SECOND THAT GETS OUT ON IN A
ROLL CALL NEXT WE HAVE.
MR LOW.
MR LAHEY PRESENTING AND TWENTY
FOUR O'TOOLE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THIS IS AB TWENTY
FOUR O. TO A TO PROVIDE CONSUMER
PROTECTION WITH RESPECT TO
CANVAS.
AND.
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO NOT
SHARE A SUCH STATE INFORMATION
WITHOUT THE CONSENT FROM
CONSUMERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE MOVED TO BOW.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS CREATE
IT CARILLO IN A SECOND BY MISTER
QUIRK.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING HAD JASON BRIAN TO
BE OF THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE SUPPORTIVE.
OF THAT THE BILL THANK YOU.
PAUL HAS VERY LOVINGLY LEGALLY
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
GRANT MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CMG
KEL EVEN SUPPORT.
THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN LOVELY IN
LEGALLY CANNABIS MEDICINE
PATIENT STRONGLY SUPPORT.
RAINY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE FINANCE NOBODY.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS THERE'S A
MOTION A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO.
THANK IT'S OUT ON.
OH I'M SORRY WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
WAIT ON THAT ONE.
I WAS JUST GONNA TO BE LOT OF
ITS REPUBLICANS.
THIS COMING AT US
.
COMMITTEE CAREER ARE YOU GONNA
PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
I KNOW I UNDERSTAND THAT.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY EIGHT IS
SUSPENSE I DON'T NEED TO PRESENT
ON IT OF HAVE TWO BILLS THAT ARE
BY MY UNDERSTANDING OR NOT IN
SUSPENSE AND NOT ON CONSENT
EITHER. I THINK THAT'S WRONG AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SIX IS ON
SUSPENSE.
OKAY.
AT THE. WE HAVE TO ONE CONSENT
THAT JUST GOT PASSED OUT MAYBE
THIRTY THIRTY IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT.
IS GOING TO BE VOTED ON TODAY
WHICH OKAY PRESENT ON THAT AYE
YES AND. IF I COULD ON.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SIX MY
UNDERSTANDING.
OUT MADAM CHAIR IT WAS THAT.
I WOULD TAKE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD MOVE IT
OFF OF THE CONSENT BUT WE CAN
DISCUSS THAT AT A LATER TIME IF
YOU WOULD IF YOU WOULD LIKE YOU
WANTED TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
ADMITTED OFF THE SUSPENSE.
YES.
WOMAN THAT'S NEXT WEEKEND THAT'S
FINE IS THAT ARE WE CAN MOVE ITS
NEXT WEEK WILL TAKE OFF THE
SUSPENSE SHIRT BUTTONS GREAT.
WOULD NOT IT MAY STILL GO ON
SUSPENSE IT'S JUST NO I THINK
THERE'S SOME CONFUSION GOING ON
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
AMENDMENTS NOW COME NOT TRYING
TO BE TO BE SNEAKING. OUT OF.
YOU CAN GO AHEAD PRESENT ON A.
B. THIRTY THIRTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEN MEMBERS I PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB THIRTY THIRTY
WHICH ATTACKS POVERTY IN EIGHT
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
DESIGNATED OPPORTUNITIES ONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT CREATES
MARKET CONDITIONS FOR PRIVATE
INVESTMENT CAPITAL. I'M THIS IS
BASICALLY A FEDERAL DESIGNATION
THAT CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
WEALTHY INVESTORS TO INVEST IN
OUR POOREST COMMUNITIES OF EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE A
DESIGNATED IN CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS.
THANK YOU KNOW THERE IS A MOTION
BY A MISTER QUIRK A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO ARE THERE SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
NO WELL.
RIGHT THAT IS GOING TO GO ON
CALL WOULD YOU LIKE TO A CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND JUST BE
VERY CLEAR SO WHAT WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SIX.
WE'RE JUST GONNA MOVE UNTIL
NEXT WEEK TO.
DEAL WITH CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU
MISS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISTER GLORIA.
IT'S LIKE YOUR NEXT.
GLORIA LOOKED TO GIVE A COUPLE
BILLS WILL START IF YOU'RE OKAY
WITHOUT WITH AB TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN.
TWENTY TWO.
TWENTY ONE NINETEEN THINGS
HONEST.
IT'S GOOD AMERICORPS HAVE AT
THAT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AB
TWENTY ONE NINETEEN CLARIFIES
THAT TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ACCESS GENDER
FROM HEALTH. TO BEHAVIORAL CARE
SERVICES.
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING YOU CAN SEE THE BILL
SECOND BAIKIE VOTE ARE
SIGNIFICANT OVER REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THEIR
PERSONAL. CARE YOU AS THEIR SOME
OF THE CARE GIVERS PRINT
PROVIDERS HARPER BY SEASON
MISINFORMATION CREATE BARRIERS
TO THEM CREEK RECEIVING
MEDICALLY NECESSARY CARE. AYE
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE A TO
WITNESSES JOHN MICHAEL EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND BACK KRAMER.
MODER.
MATTER VERY CLOSELY. WITH A CELL
YOU CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
WE AGREE WITH THE ANALYSIS THAT
THE COSTS ARE MINOR AND WE THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR PUTTING THAT
TOGETHER. AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO STATE THE CO SPONSORSHIP OF
NATIONAL CENTER FOR LESBIAN
RIGHTS AND LINDA LEGAL WHO COULD
NOT BE HERE TODAY WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BECCA CAME OUT ON BEHALF OF ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA ALL KEEP IT
SUPORT AND KICK OFF MEET HIS.
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED BY A CO
SPONSOR LA LGBT SENATE TO.
I REPRESENT THEM AND ALSO
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
WHO ARE ALSO SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
KATHY SAID KNOWING WHAT THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
BECAUSE IN OPPOSITION SEEN NINE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE KNOW FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS.
WHICH I CLOSE MISTER GLORIA I
WOULD JUST ADD TO THE COMMENTS
OF MY WITNESSES THE. BILL HAS
POTENTIAL MINOR COSTS BY THINK
THESE OUTWEIGHED BY THE BENEFITS
THAT PEOPLE DID PROVIDE TEMAS
ONE WILL YOU TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR.
IT WILL BE TAKEN OUT OF AN
IMMINENT.
IF WE CAN GET SOME MORE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE.
I'M.
NEXT I AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY TWO
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT THIS
BILL ADDS A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE CITY MOVING NOW.
THANK YOU.
YOU BOTH A CITY A REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE CITY SAN DIEGO AS A NON
VOTING MEMBER TO NOT COUNTY
TRANSIT DISTRICT ALSO NODES IN
CT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
THOSE.
AND. RICHARD DARMAN WE HAVE NO
CALTRANS A DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
ALONG WITH THE DISTRICTS
CONTRACTING LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR AND THE CHAIRS AB EIGHT OH
FIVE FROM LAST YEAR. REGRETS
ENERGIES FOR TRANSIT THE REGION
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
PART OF FINANCE NOVA.
SEEN NO QUIET AT.
QUESTIONS THAT HAS A MOTION BY
MISTER QUIRK.
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO AND WE
WILL TAKE IT UP WHEN WE IT'S
MORE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE
WHICH I DON'T LOS.
JUST LIKE WE ASK FOR A VOTE
MEETINGS AND WATCH.
MISTER KANSEN CHU.
MISTER CHAIR I THINK YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING ON A. B. THREE ZERO
EIGHT EIGHT CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT MOMENT AND SHARE.
NO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAIR REMEMBERS AB THREE ZERO
EIGHT A REQUIRE. ALL CONTINUING
CARE RETIREMENT COMMUNITY TO
STUDY. AND DISCLOSE MOBITEL BY
NATURE RISK SUCH AS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE COSTS IN THEIR
FACILITY.
TWO BROTHER PLAYING FOR IMPEDE
AND CALLS AND LIMIT FUND ISSUE
IMPACT
TO THE RESIDENTS AND TODAY WAS
ME HERE. THAT THEIR ANSWER THE
TECHNICAL QUESTION IS MORE CAN A
CABA HALL REPRESENTING CALLED
FOR NEAR CONTINUING CARE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MORNING CARD HOLDER
AND A STRATEGY GROUP ON HOW THE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUING CARE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION THE SOUL
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING THE
RESIDENTS OF CCR SEIZING
CALIFORNIA. I'M JUST HERE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WORSE AS THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL BELIEVE THIS IS JUST A
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE TOOL TO
BE USED BY ALL THE PROVIDERS.
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IF THEY COME UP AND I
OR DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
PETER CALLOUSED ON BEHALF OF
LEADING AIDS CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
THE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING NOT
FOR PROFIT CONTINUING CARE
RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES. THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ON
POLICY GROUNDS HAVE MET WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS.
HAVE YET TO REALLY IDENTIFY AN
ACTUAL NEED FOR THE BILL GIVEN
THAT THE IN ENABLING LEGISLATION
FOR TAIPEI CONTRACT SPECIFICALLY
EXCLUDED. BNC CONTRACTS WHICH
THIS BILL APPLIES TO AND THE
SPONSORS DID SUPPORT BACK BILL
SO WE REMAIN OPPOSED ON POLICY.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION.
PART OF FINANCE NO FILE.
I. QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER CHAIRMAN. OF FIGURE
VERY MUCH AND AGAIN THIS WILL
ONLY. APPLY TO THE BNC CONTRACT
AND I.
URGE YOUR BIBLE.
WE WILL TAKE THAT UP AS SOON AS
WE GETS MORE FOLKS HERE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER KALRA ARE YOU PREPARED
TO.
YES OKAY.
MISTER KALRA.
I HAVE HERE THAT YOU'RE
PRESENTING ON TWO BILLS ONE OF
WHICH IS ON SUSPENSE.
ONLY ONE OF YOU DOING THIS.
SO YOU WILL BE PRESENTING FIRST
ON AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MAY I MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS. FOR THE OPTIMISM AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN AB TWO TWENTY
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN.
WOULD ALLOW VETERINARIANS
DISCUSSED THE USE OF CANNABIS
WITHOUT FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
LICENSE BOTH ABOUT SECOND.
AND ENABLES COUNT ESTIMATE
MEDICINAL ANIMAL USED TO BE
ACCESSIBLE TO CONSUMERS AND
REGULATED DISPENSARIES TO ENSURE
COUNTIES PRODUCTS WINNER SO YOU
SAW ANIMALS. TO BE AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS REGGAE MARKING AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN AS THESE
PRINT PRODUCTS TO THE DEFINITION
UNDER THE MEDICINE ADULT USE
CANNABIS REGULATIONS SAFETY ACT.
THIS WILL ENABLE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO COME TO MARKET THAT
ARE SAFE FOR PET USE. RATHER PET
OWNERS USING CANNABIS PRODUCTS
DESIGNED FOR HUMAN USE ON THEIR
PETS.
I SAY IN THE NOW SAYS THE DOES
MINOR ACOSTA SPECIAL FUNDS THAT
DO NOT PLACE BURDEN ON THE
STATE'S GENERAL FUND.
THANK YOU THAT HAS IN MOTION.
BY MISS CREATE A SECOND BY
MISTER QUIRK SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
BAND CHEN MEMBERS MIGHT DILLON
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
GETTING PEOPLE ON BEHALF OF THE
LONG BEACH COLLECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SPORT.
ANNIE JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SPORT.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MORNING.
BILLION LEGALLY.
FORMER CURRICULAR CURRICULA
DEVELOPER SCIENTIFIC ILLUSTRATOR
INSTRUCTORS HAVEN'T CISCO SPCA
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF SCIENCES.
WE'VE BEEN MAKING RATIO SPECIFIC
AND CONDITION SPECIFIC CANNABIS
BASED FORMULAS FOR OVER A DECADE
WORKING WITH VETERINARIANS
RESEARCHERS AND PHYSICIANS.
TO FURTHER RESPONSIBLE
ADMINISTRATION OF CANNABIS
MEDICINE
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN IS NEEDED
LEGISLATION BUT AS WRITTEN IT
DOES NOTHING. TO EDUCATE
VETERINARIANS NOR DOES IT
FURTHER RESEARCH AND POSES AN
UNDUE FINANCIAL BURDEN ON THE
CVM BE. THERE IS NO RECREATIONAL
USE OF CANNABIS FOR ANIMALS DOGS
IN PARTICULAR HAVE MORE
CANNABINOID RECEPTORS THAN ANY
OTHER ANIMAL INCLUDING HUMANS.
STAFF AND DISPENSARIES ARE
UNTRAINED IN ADMINISTRATION OF
CANNABIS BASED MEDICINES FOR
ANIMALS THE ONLY PROTECTION THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN TWENTY TWO
FIFTEENS LANGUAGE. WAS THE
CABBIE AT THE VETERINARY
CANNABIS BE AVAILABLE IN MEDICAL
DISPENSARIES ONLY LET LANGUAGE
WAS STRUCK AFTER TWO FIFTEEN
PASSED THE BNP COMMITTEE.
THAT'S MOVING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION WE STRONGLY URGE A NO
VOTE UNTIL TWO FIFTEEN IS
AMENDED WITH STRUGGLE LANGUAGE
PROTECTING ANIMALS EDUCATING
VETERINARIANS AND GIVING
VETERINARIANS THE ABILITY TO
RECOMMEND THANK YOU.
YEAH.
THE LOCAL HAND.
PAUL HANDS VERY LOVINGLY
LEGALLY.
WE'VE BEEN DOING WORKING WITH
RESEARCHERS DOCTORS FOR OVER A
DECADE SUPPLYING OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS. MEDICINE FOR SEVERELY
ILL.
PATIENTS.
FOR THE LANGUAGE NEEDS TO BE
MORE COMPREHENSIVE. WE HAVE MET
WITH THE OF VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD ON A NUMBER OF OCCASIONS
WE'VE SPOKEN WITH THE AUTHOR.
EXISTS AGAIN THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL AS WRITTEN THAT
PROTECTS THIS IS THE SAFETY OF
ANIMALS. IT DOES NOTHING TO
FURTHER THAT THE PROFESSION OF
VETERINARY. IT DOES NOTHING TO
FURTHER RESEARCH.
PEOPLE NEED THE RESEARCH THEY
NEED A BODY OF EVIDENCE THIS IS
ONE WAY TO GET A DOCUMENT A BODY
OF EVIDENCE BY. ALLOWING THE
VETERINARIANS TO OF TO RECOMMEND
AND ALSO TO.
.
HOW THE OF RECOMMENDATION FOR IN
ORDER TO PURCHASE THESE
VETERINARY?
THINGS THE VETERINARIAN MEDICAL
CANNABIS.
WE HAVE MET WITH THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD IT BACK IN
DECEMBER THEY HAD EMERGENCY
TELECONFERENCE A BOARD MEETING.
IN ORDER TO RAISE THEIR FEES
BECAUSE IN ORDER TO MEET THEIR
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITIES.
THE THE STATEMENT THAT IS MINOR
COST DUE TO THE CONTINGENCY FUND
I THINK THAT THE THEIR FOR THEIR
OF FISCAL OF.
POSITION IS IS STRAINED AS IT IS
AND THEY WOULD HAVE LIKELY HAVE
TO HIRE.
RESEARCHERS LAWYERS AND
CONSULTANTS BECAUSE BY AND LARGE
THE VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD
KNOWS VERY LITTLE ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF MEDICAL CANNABIS.
SO IN ORDER TO DO THEIR WORK
EFFECTIVELY THAT WOULD HAVE TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL PEOPLE.
I THINK OF WE HAVE LANGUAGE IS
ALREADY BEEN VETTED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL THAT WOULD
FIT PLUG FIT INTO THIS QUITE.
READILY IN CRATE QUITE EASILY
INCLUDING CONTINUING EDUCATION
FOR THE VETERINARIANS IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO BE QUALIFIED TO
RECOMMEND.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT OF WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
LISTEN LANGUAGES.
INCLUDED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THEIR THERE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
PART IN FINANCE NO FILE THANK
YOU.
MISTER KALRA ARE YOU COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION.
WE DIDN'T WORK WITH EVERYONE.
THAT THE BEST WE CAN.
THEIR DIVERSE OPINION. AS TO
HOW TO PROCEED.
BUT PROBABLY THE WORKING MOSTLY
WITH THE BOARD AS WELL AS
MEDICAL THE VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS THE
VETERINARIANS THANK YOU.
MR CRACK ARM.
I JUST LIKE TO GET HER. TO SAY
THAT I'M CERTAINLY VOTING FOR
TODAY ON FINANCIAL GRANTS
HOWEVER.
I DO ONE UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE
BEHIND THIS AND IF THE VARIOUS
PARTIES CAN MEET WITH ME I'D BE
INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT MORE
THANK YOU.
THE CAPE MISTER BIGELOW HAS
QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
.
CAN READ THE BILL I'M KIND OF
CURIOUS.
EXPLAIN TO US HOW AND WHAT
PRODUCT WILL BE USED.
IN A BENEFICIAL WAY AND WHAT
WHAT TYPE OF USE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE RIGHT
NOW BUT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE THE THE USE OF CANNABIS ON
ON ANIMALS REALLY.
BUT LIMIT CERTAIN FOLKS ON CBD
WHICH IS THE MEDICINAL COMPONENT
OF CANNABIS NOT TEENAGE SEE.
WHICH IS THE COMPONENT THAT
CREATES THE HIGH.
AND SO THERE IS EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH THAT HAS BEEN DONE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE DONE.
IN WORKING WITH THIS BILL WE
ARE. WE HAVE BEEN IN CONSTANT
CONTACT WITH IN FACT.
OF WILL CONTINUE TO BE CASA
CONTACT WITH RESEARCHERS AND
THIS BILL DOES.
.
THAT PART OF THE BILL IS TO
PERSONAL ALLOW VETERINARIANS TO
LEAST DISCUSS WHAT THEIR PATIENT
OWNERS CANNABIS AYE IT'S UP THE
VETERINARIAN TO WANT TO DO THAT.
EYES SO. THERE'S NO.
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THEY MUST
BUT IN ADDITION IT IT COULD DIED
OF THE BOARD TO CREATE
GUIDELINES AND SAW THAT WOULD
ALLOW GOING FORWARD. TO USE THE
SCIENCE THE RESEARCH AS IT IS
ONGOING RESEARCH TO ENSURE THAT
WHEN SOMEONE GOES IN DISPENSED
ME THERE'S ACTUALLY GUIDANCE FOR
THE DISPENSARY.
AS TO. WHAT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ADMITTED TO?
THE PAINT TO PET OWNERS AND SO
ABSOLUTELY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THE REASON WHY THIS BILL I
WAS PUT FORWARD. WISE IN ORDER
TO CREATE SOME KIND OF BASIS.
AS OPPOSED TO NOT HAVING ANY
RULES AT ALL. AYE AND CERTAINLY
TO REMOVE LIABILITY FOR
VETERINARIANS WHO HAVE NO
ABILITY TO EVEN DISCUSS CANNABIS
WITH THEIR PATIENT OWNERS SOBER
MOOD LIABILITY WORK TOWARDS
CREATING THE GUIDELINES AND
ALLOW DISPENSARIES TO DISPENSE
AT AND I THINK THAT THOSE THAT
COMBINATION OF THOSE THREE
THINGS. BROADBAND CHILE JUST AS
THE BELT THAT THE BUREAU RIGHT
NOW IS PUTTING TOGETHER THESE
GUIDELINES THIS.
OF.
THIS GUIDANCE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE WILL ALLOW THE
BUREAU TO IN ADDITION.
THAT IN ADDITION TO THE WORK
IT'S DOING IN TERMS OF HUMAN USE
ALLOW THEM TO ALSO WORK WITH THE
VETERINARY BOARD THAT OF
VETERINARY MEDICINE UP OF. TO
ENSURE THAT IF THE SUSPENSE
RESPONSIBLY BECAUSE OF COURSE IT
CAN ONLY BE DISPENSED FOR
MEDICAL AILMENTS O. FOR PATIENT
HONORS IN THE REASON WHY. IT WAS
MOVED FROM THE MEDICINAL TO THE
RECREATIONAL IS THAT A PET CAN
GET A MEDICAL CANNABIS CARD.
AND SO IS THE CREDIT THAT THIS
WAS TO THE SUGGESTION OF THE BMP
COMMITTEE PUBLIC CHAIR LOW AND
AND TE STAFF DOING A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK. THAT IT WAS
MOVED TO THE RECREATIONAL AT
THIS IS NOT ABOUT PETS GETTING
RECREATIONAL USE OF CANNABIS AT
ALL.
RIGHT UNDERSTANDING THAT FROM
THE MEDICAL PERSPECTIVE BUT
THERE'S ONLY SEVERAL WAYS THAT
AN ANIMAL CAN.
.
THE AFFECTED BY THIS ONE IS
EITHER THROUGH A SUBCUTANEOUS
INJECTION TO FROM AN
INTRAMUSCULAR THREE FROM OUR A
NASAL MIST OR ORAL A
ADMINISTRATION THOSE ARE THE
ONLY METHODS. OF THAT YOU CAN
REALLY IF I GET THIS PRODUCT AND
SITE THOSE ALL REQUIRED FTA
LEVEL OF APPROVAL WITH
CERTIFICATION THAT THE PRODUCT
IS HEALTHY AND SAFE. FOR THE.
AND ANIMAL THAT'S BEING.
USE FOR THIS UNLESS WE'RE GOING
TO USE SOME KIND OF FORM OF LIKE
A SCOOBY SNACK YOU KNOW WE PUT
IT INSIDE. STUFF TO MAKE FUN OF
IT IS JUST THEN TOOK BECAUSE
SAVE THE WAY IT IS YOU WOULD PUT
IT IN SOMETHING. THAT WOULD BE A
TREAT FOR THE ANIMAL WHETHER IT
BE DOG CAT WHATEVER TO TO TO
INGEST THERE ALSO AND JUST KIND
OF CURIOUS HOW WE'RE GONNA
HAMLET. WITHOUT GOING THROUGH
THE FDA WELL FIRST LAWS
WONDERING HOW LONG THIS BILL
WOULD BE EXISTS FOR SOMEONE
ACTUALLY REFERRED TO SCOOBY
SNACKS.
BUT I'D THAT THE REALITY IS THAT
THERE ARE A THAT YOU'RE CORRECT
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE WAYS THAT
YOU COULD CERTAINLY GET AN
ANIMAL TO INJUSTICE BUT THERE
ALSO ARE. LOTIONS AND AND AND
POTIONS LOTIONS AND SUCH FOR
EXTERNAL USE FOR MUSCLE ACHES
WHAT HAVE YOU. ADAPTING SAID THE
FDA OF COURSE HASN'T.
APPROVED OF CANNABIS FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION.
SO THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT OF. THE
STATE.
BASED UPON NOT JUST WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PUT FORWARD BUT
BASED UPON THE VOTE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS. HAS. ALLOWED HIM FOR
AT LEAST A STATE REPORT
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S THIS TENSION
THAT EXISTS EVEN FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND SO.
THIS IN NO WAY AND THAT'S WHY
MAKE IT COULD THIS IN NO WAY
REQUIRES A VETERINARIAN.
MY TO DISCUSS THIS WITH PATIENT
OWNERS OR NOR IS A REQUIRE
DISPENSARY TO SELL FOR. OF
ANIMAL USE BECAUSE THERE'S
ALWAYS THAT RISK WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HOWEVER YOU
KNOW I STILL REMAIN OPTIMISTIC
THAT AT SOME POINT FTA.
ALL WORLD OF. BUT WILL BE MORE
OF A POSITIVE IN A SERB. MILITIA
SHIP WITH BUT STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA THAT ALLOW FOR SO I I
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE IT
READS.
PLEASE US INTO THE NEXT LEVEL OF
QUESTIONS
YOU KNOW THERE'S A.
A FEDERAL LAW.
THAT REQUIRES A WITHDRAWAL
PERIOD FOR ALL PRESCRIBED
MEDICINES
AND IF YOU'RE SELLING LIVESTOCK
AND YOU'VE TREATED IT. LIKE IF
YOU TREATED WITH A ANTIBIOTIC IN
A RECENT YEAH YOU HAVE TO WAIT
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS BEFORE YOU CAN
SELL THAT ANIMAL OR IT CAN BE
PROCESSED TO GOING TO THE FOOD
CHAIN. OR BE UTILIZED.
SOME PEOPLE IF THEY'RE STARTING
TO USE THIS NOW THEY'RE USING
OUTLOOK JUST LIKE LAMBS OR
HAIG'S OR CATTLE. YEAH IT.
COULD VERY EASILY GET INTO THE
FOOD STREAM IF THERE'S NO
REGULATORY STATUTE.
TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM THIS AND
PEOPLE COULDN'T JUST THAT.
AND BE AFFECTED SO I THINK
THERE'S SOME CURIOSITY HERE THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME STANDARDS.
THAT WAY AND AT LEAST HAVE A
RECOGNITION.
OF WHAT THOSE IMPACTS MIGHT BE.
I I DO WANT TO POINT OUT I
APPRECIATE WESLEYAN AND I THINK
IF SOME OF THESE ISSUES MIGHT OF
I DON'T I DON'T WATCH BMP I
DON'T HAVE THESE ISSUES WERE
BROUGHT UP. IT COULD AFFECT THE
COST BUT I DO WANT TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT.
THIS COMMITTEE REALLY IS MAKING
A DECISION BASED ON ON THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS SO BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS I HAVE
SOME OF THE SAME SO. WITH THAT I
THINK MISS CARILLO HAD A
QUESTION AND THEN MISS FRIEDMAN.
IT WAS YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
ONE THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL TO OUR ATTENTION I'M A PET
OWNER KNOW SEVERAL. FRIENDS WHO
LIVES WHOSE DOGS.
SUFFERED FROM CANCER ARTHRITIS
AND THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND ENSURING THAT WERE
USING SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY TO
FIGURE OUT SOLUTIONS.
FOR SOME OF THESE HUMAN BASS
ILLNESSES AND OUR PETS HAVE AND
I. LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A
CONVERSATION.
ABOUT SOME OF THE LAYOUTS OF
MISTER BIGELOW POINTED OUT.
.
IN A POLICY CONVERSATION OUTSIDE
OF THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU
THINK.
THIS FRIEDMAN.
I MEAN YEAH I SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY BECAUSE OF THE FISCAL
IMPACT BUT I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT IT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
FLOOR. A WITH REGARDS TO THE
SAFETY.
FOR PETS THANK YOU.
THE SUPPORTING TODAY JUST BASED
ON FISCAL IMPACTS.
.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M EVEN
QUALIFIED TO SAY THE SHOULD
HAPPEN ACTION HAPPEN SO I HAD
THIS IS A DIFFICULT DECISION BUT
I I GUESS. WHAT YOU'RE BEING
ASKED ASKING US TO DO IS MOVE IT
FORWARD SO THAT THAT?
VETERINARIANS CAN DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT THIS SHOULD BE MOVE
FORWARD WHICH I'M MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH AN BE MAKING
THAT KIND OF DECISION.
.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IF
THERE'S NO MORE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ABSOLUTELY THAT'S
THE REASON WHY WE'RE REMOVING AT
A PACE THAT ALLOWS THE
VETERINARIANS TO ACTUALLY GUIDE
US IN THE RESEARCH TO GUIDE US.
AND NOT TO MAKE PRESUMPTIONS BUT
WE DO KNOW THAT A NUMBER OF
ANIMALS DO HAVE THE SAME
RECEPTORS THAT ALLOW FOR
BENEFITS AND CBD AND AND RIGHT
NOW PEOPLE ARE GIVING. CANNABIS
TO THEIR PETS THAT IS DESIGNED
FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE CANNABIS ARE
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR PET
CONSUMPTION WE CANNOT DO THIS
WITHOUT. A BIT THAT A BILL OF
THIS NATURE GOING FORWARD SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH MR BROKE VOTING
BY.
TO KALRA.
I HAVE DOWN THAT YOU'RE.
GOING TO ATTEMPT TO PRESENT ON
AB TWENTY THIRTY THREE IT'S A.
BILL THAT HAS BEEN MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR. DID YOU NOTICE
WE HAD TWO HUNDRED TWO BILLS
TODAY O. OKAY SO I'LL BE VERY
BRIEF THAT. I AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY THREE WOULD INCREASE
NUMBER OF SLOTS AVAILABLE UNDER
THIS SYSTEM LEADING WAIVER
PROGRAM BY UP TO EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED FROM THE
CURRENT THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED.
EXPAND YOUR GRAPHIC
REPRESENTATION THE PROGRAM ON A
REGIONAL BUTTE BASIS TO ALLOW
FOR THE SLOTS BE MORE READILY
AVAILABLE ON RULE A COMMUNITIES.
I OUTLINED REQUIREMENTS THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND ADDRESS
VARIOUS PROGRAMMATIC ALMOST
IMPACTS EFFECTIVENESS.
THIS IS A LETTER TO WAIVER
PROGRAM TAKE SENIORS IN NURSING
HOMES WHO DON'T NEED THAT LEVEL
OF CARE AND PLACES THEM IN
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY. OR
ALLOW SENIORS TO REMAIN AT HOME
WITH THE APPROPRIATE SERVICES
AND THEREBY AVOID BEING PLACED
IN A NURSING HOME AND BOY IF
BOTH CASES BY AVOIDING THE HIGH
COST OF NURSING HOME CARE.
ESPECIALLY SAYS THAT LEVEL CARES
UNNECESSARY PROVIDES A COST
SAVINGS THE STATE.
FURTHERMORE IT FREES UP VALUABLE
NURSING HOME BEDS FOR THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY NEED THEM A WIN WIN FOR
EVERYONE.
CURRENTLY DEMAND PROCESS LIVING
WAIVER PROGRAMS OUTPACE SUPPLY
AND OPERATES WITH A SIGNIFICANT
WAITLIST.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTSCORECARD ALMOST ELEVEN
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS ONE
HUNDRED ONE THOUSAND NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS ARE ELEVEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS. IDENTIFIED
AS HAVING LOW CARE NEEDS
BY EXPANDING THE EXITS LEADING
WINNER PROGRAM WE COULD PLACE
THOSE ELEVEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS IN THE MOST
APPROPRIATE SETTING THEY BELONG.
WHERE THEIR BEST CARE FORUM
WHERE THEY WOULD BE HAPPIEST
THIS COULD ALL BE DONEIN A
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO THE
STATE?
WERE STAFF COMMENTS NOW SAYS WE
ARE MOVING THE REPORT PROVIDER
RATE INCREASES AND I WOULD ALSO
ADD THAT ANY ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS ASSOCIATE WITH THIS BILL.
WILL BE MORE THAN OFFSET BY
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS.
I'M SUSAN DEMERITS THOUSAND
ASSOCIATIONS HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NUMBERS THAT FAST
RIBA.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS INSTEAD MARK
GOOD MORNING SUSAN TO MORRIS ON
BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION TODAY ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES.
ARE LIVING WITH ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE AND COULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS WAIVER YET ITS CAPTIVE
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED AND LIMITED
TO ONLY.
COUNTIES WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
AND WE'RE JOINED BY MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SPEAKERS AND SPORT ABOUT MALE
REPRESENTING SIX BED ZINC
ASSOCIATION OF MORE THAN TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED SMALL ASSISTED
LIVING.
SO THESE IN SUPPORT.
LISA COLEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE
NO FILE.
WHICH I TO. STEADFAST AND I
DON'T THINK.
AND WE'LL TAKE THAT UP WITH THE
SUSPENSE CALENDAR THANK YOU.
STERN ARE.
MISS FRIEDMAN.  I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T SEE IN THE AUDIENCE
MISTER WOULD.
MISTER WOULD YOU WILL BE PER SE
ON AB TWENTY SIX FORTY IT ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS A MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR DECADES
TRIBES ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS IN
THE FISHING COMMUNITY OF WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO REOPEN THE
OVER FOUR HUNDRED MILES OF
FISHING. FISH SPAWNING HABITAT
UPSTREAM OF THE KLAMATH DAMS TO
NATIVE FISH SPECIES.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
OREGON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND PACIFICORP CAME TO AN
AGREEMENT THAT SET PLANS IN
MOTION TO REMOVE THE FOUR DAMS
THAT CURRENTLY STAND ON THE
KLAMATH RIVER.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THE AUTHORITY TO AUTHORIZE THE
TAKE OR POSSESSION. THE LOST
RIVER SECTOR FISH AND THE SUGAR
MILL SUCKED SECONDS RESULTED
FROM IMPACTS ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE
REMOVAL OF KLAMATH DAMS
THE BILL WOULD GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO PROTECT
THESE TWO ENDANGERED SPECIES OF
SACRIFICIAL. PROVIDE LEGAL
PROTECTIONS FOR THE PARTIES
DURING THE CLIMATE DAM REMOVAL
PROCESS HERE TESTIFYING BEHALF.
IS OF THE BILL IS I CAL TROUT
WITH CAL TROUT IS MARK SMITH.
MANAGER ROOM MEMBERS MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA TROUT AS
YOU KNOW WE'VE SET ASIDE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROPOSITION ONE PASSED BY THE
VOTERS IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. TO
FACILITATE THE REMOVAL OF THESE
DAMS WE APPRECIATE THE DISMAL
LEGISLATION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE STATE AND
THE STATE OF OREGON ON THE
PROCESS OF DAM REMOVAL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
I REQUEST WOMAN FRIENDS THE
RIVER IN SUPPORT.
THINK IT UP SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO
FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WIDGET THERE
IS A MOTION.
BY MISTER QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO OR VICE VERSA WHICH
YOU LIKE CLOTHES RESPECT LAST
YEAR AGO. AND WILL TAKE THAT UP
AS SOON AS I CAN GET ONE MORE
PERSON INTO THIS COMMITTEE.
THINK ABOUT THANK YOU MISTER
WOULD.
MISTER LACKEY.
MR LIKE A.
I SEE YOU'RE GONNA PRESENT ON A.
B. NINETEEN TWENTY NINE IT IS A.
A BILL THAT HAS BEEN MADE TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE.
YES MA'AM.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THE HAVING A FEW
MOMENTS HERE I KNOW YOU HAVE A
VERY ON.
LACKEY.
LIST OF RESPONSIBILITY BUT I DO
BELIEVE THIS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT SAW TRY TO BE COGENT
HERE REALLY QUICKLY THANK YOU.
LIKE TO PRESENT A BEACH
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE.
EACH YEAR THE STATE SPENDS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON PROGRAMS
INTENDED TO REHABILITATE
INDIVIDUALS.
IT ONLY MAKES SENSE TO
CONTINUOUSLY EVALUATE THESE
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE EACH ARMENIAN
THAT THE INVASION GOALS.
AB NOT YOU TWENTY NINE WOULD
CALL THE CDC ARE AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL. TO EVALUATE
CORRECTIONAL REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS.
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH
ORGANIZATIONS WILL CONDUCT
EVALUATIONS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
SELECTED REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
ARE COST EFFECTIVE.
OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD.
RESEARCH WILL PRIORITIZE THE
EVALUATION OF PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDED WITH STATE FUNDS AND
SERVE THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
INMATES.
THIS BILL IN BODIES TO LA O.
RECOMMENDATIONS GIVEN IN A
REPORT WHICH SHALL OUTLINED HOW
TO APPROVE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS.
IT'S ALSO CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION THE MOST RECENT
REPORT. BY THE CALIFORNIA
REHABILITATION OVERSIGHT BOARD
THAT STRESSES QUOTE THE
IMPORTANCE OF MEASURING PROGRAM
IN IMPLEMENTATION AND OUTCOMES.
AND TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE
LONGER TERM OUTCOMES AFTER
OFFENDERS HAVE BEEN RELEASED
INTO THE COMMUNITY CLOSE QUOTE.
THIS BILL ONLY ASK FOR
INFORMATION TO BE GATHERED BY
THOSE. A WITH EXPERTISE TO
CORRECTIONAL REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS.
NOTHING IN THE BILL REQUIRES ANY
PROGRAMS TO BE ELIMINATED BETTER
PROGRAMS MEAN A BETTER QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR CARCERI TO PEOPLE
AND ULTIMATELY LOWER RECIDIVISM
RATES.
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU SIR OTHERS SPEAKERS
AND SPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO WHILE.
THANK YOU MR NGHE SI NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CONCLUDE.
IT JUST REAL QUICKLY.
I DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO.
REDUCE THE BILL'S COST ADDRESS
SOME OF THE TECHNICAL ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED IN PUBLIC
SAFETY.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT NOT
BILL WILL BE MOVED TO SUSPEND
SCRAPPING TAKE YOU.
IT'S FRIEDMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT TO YOU.
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE FIRST.
YES TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY FIVE REQUIRES THE
SECRETARY OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY TO TAKE ACTION
TO ADD ANY CALIFORNIA WHERE THE
BILL. IN THE NATIONAL WILD AND
SCENIC RIVER SYSTEM THAT IS
REMOVED DELISTED AGREES
PROTECTIONS OR WEAKENED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THE STATE
WILD AND SCENIC RIVERS SYSTEM IT
IS NOT ALREADY PART OF THAT
SYSTEM. WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPONENTS AND OF RECENTLY
PROVIDED THEM WITH A LIST OF
AMENDMENTS WERE WILLING TO MAKE
INCLUDING.
THAT THE BILL WILL PERMIT
SECRETARIAL DESIGNATION BUT
ALLOWS THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR STATUTORILY REPEAL OR
MODIFY THE DESIGNATION AT ANY
TIME AND TO LIMIT STATE RIVERS
PROTECTION IN THIS CHAPTER TO
ONLY FEDERAL RIVERS. AS OF
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND THEIR EXISTING GEOGRAPHICAL
LINK.
WITH ME TODAY TO IN SUPPORT OF
A. B.. TWO NINE SEVEN FIVE IS
OUR WESSELMANN WITH FRIENDS OF
THE RIVER AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THINK IT WAS FRIEDMAN SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
I'M SORRY YEAH.
I'M AIRBUS MY EXECUTIVE FRIENDS
OF THE RIVER PICKING RIVERS
COMPANY FOR THE FORTY FIVE
YEARS.
IT'S VERY NEAR A BILL IT
BETWEEN I THIRTY FIVE PROVIDE A
SAFETY NET FOR EXISTING
FEDERALLY PROTECTED RIVER SO WE
ARE YOUR I WANT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. MANAGER WOMAN MEMBERS
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DROUGHT ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
SHOSHANA MITCHELL ME TO.
THERESA SOME SOME AN AMERICAN
WHITEWATER YES.
ROBERT FRIENDS OF THE RIVER YES.
MELINDA BOOTH THE SOUTH YUBA
RIVER CITIZENS LEAGUE STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
REUVEN CHILDRESS WITH FIDEL
CONSERVANCY.
SUPPORT.
TOM DALY ONLY RIVERVIEW
FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
LOW LAST FALL UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FLY FISHERS
INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT.
DAVID BELONG PRESIDENT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FLY FISHERS IN THAT.
SUPPORT.
VERY PEACH CONSERVATION CHAIRMAN
FOR PROTECT AMERICAN RIVER
CANYONS IN SUPPORT AND I HAVE.
POSTCARD SIGNED IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
IT.
CLEARLY WENT WITH FRIENDS OF THE
RIVER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
HOW NOT CAMILO THE CALPERS
DECISION WHITE GRAPE GROWERS I'M
WE'VE WORKED WITH THE AUTHOR AND
A NUMBER OF ISSUES OR AT THE FOR
MAKING PROGRESS? OUR CONCERN IS
THAT WE WANT HEAVY MEANINGFUL
PUBLIC PROCESS THAT THE PUBLIC
IS OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN AND
THAT WE DON'T GO FURTHER THAN
THE FEDERAL DESIGNATION. I THINK
THIS COMES AGENTS ARE GOING WELL
AND VERY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR HOPEFULLY
RESULTING REMAINING ISSUES
BEFORE IT'S TAKE UP ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR THINKING.
THANK YOU.
ELLERY NARROW FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WERE IN THE
SAME PLACE AND REALLY HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN WORK THROUGH
AMENDMENTS OUT.
THOMAS CARS WITH THE GLOCK GROUP
ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS KINGS
RIVER WATER CESSATION KINGS HERE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT IN THE
UNITED WATER CONSERVATION
DISTRICT IN ABOUT IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT DEPARTMENT FINANCE
NOBLE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE%
TO CONCLUDE. WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
HOPEFULLY THEY WON'T BE
OPPONENTS MUCH LONGER.
I THINK IT WAS FRIEDMAN IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU HAVE ONE WE WILL TAKE
THAT UP OF COURSE WHEN.
WE GET ONE MORE DEMOCRAT ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
IN FACT IF MR BONTA MISTER
CALDERON MISS EGGMAN OR MISTER
GARCIA.
IS AVAILABLE TO BE GREAT.
COME ON DOWN.
AND THE NEXT BILL IS AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTY TWO IT ENJOYS A DIM
PASS AS AMENDED.
I'VE ASSUME YOU'RE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE BOTTOM
CHAIR WE ARE VERY HAPPY TO TAKE
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER BIGELOW IN A SECOND BY
MISTER QUIRK ME PROCEED.
THANK YOU THIS BILL IS.
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP BILL TO HELP
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES MORE EFFECTIVELY
ADMINISTER AND MANAGE THE STATE
ISSUANCE OF LICENSES RESIDENTIAL
ALCOHOL AND DRUG ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITIES WITH THE CAPACITY OF
SIX OR LESS PEOPLE.
AS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU TIME TO TAKE MY JOB
THAT WAS QUICK.
ADDITIONAL A SUPPORTERS GIVE
MEDICARE ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN MARCOS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
LIMON COUNCILMEMBER CITY OF
MALIBU AND REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTS CITIES A
WE'VE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLUGINS ALWAYS HERE BE
OUT TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY'S A DIME OF OUR THOUSAND
OAKS IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPRIVED OF FINANCE SO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTION SWITCH I TO.
WRAP UP NO.
GREAT APPETITE ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISTREATMENT.
HEARD NAZARIAN.
WHY MISTER NAZARIAN GOES UP
THERE I WILL REMIND UM THE
FOLLOWING AUTHORS THAT WE STILL
NEED THEM MISTER GIPSON ON?
?
MISTER OF BONTA.
MISTER AS AARON THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I'M PRESENTING TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY THE CLEAN AND
HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT THIS BILL
REQUIRES ALL KEY TO TWELVE
SCHOOLS. WITH FIFTY OR MORE
STUDENTS TO SWITCH TO SAFER
ENVIRONMENTALLY PREFERABLE
CLEANING PRODUCTS.
OR MORE SIMPLY GREEN CLEANING
PRODUCTS.
GREEN CLEANING PRODUCTS ARE
THOSE THAT ARE INDEPENDENTLY
CERTIFIED BY A THIRD PARTY AS
HAVING GREATLY REDUCED EFFECTS
ON HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT POSE A BILL.
SCHOOLS ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO
SWITCH TO GREEN CLEANING
PRODUCTS.
IF IT IS ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE
AND WILL HAVE NO NET COST
INCREASE IN REALITY ALMOST EVERY
INSTITUTION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAS ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY AFTER
SWITCHING TO GREEN CLEANING
PRODUCTS.
BY REQUIRING SCHOOLS TO SWITCH
TO GREEN CLEANING PRODUCTS AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY WILL HELP
AVOID. THE USE OF CLEANING
PRODUCTS THAT ARE HARMFUL TO
TEACHERS STUDENTS AND CUSTODIAL
STAFF.
WHO HAVE THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
EXPOSURE?
WITH ME IS BILL ELLIOTT.
THANK YOU GREAT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND.
BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY MISS
FRIEDMAN.
SUPPORTERS BILL ELLIOTT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP THAT
SPONSORED THE BILL.
WE SAVE COSTS ROOM AT LAST
HEALTHCARE ISSUES WITH ASTHMA
WITH CHATTERS TEACHERS KIDS AND
WE HAVE EXAMPLES FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE THAT THEY SAVE MONEY
SWITCHING TO GREEN PRODUCTS
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
MEDICARE TONY TO CARE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WHERE IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING NICOLE CAN UNITS
HERE ON BEHALFOF THE HOUSEHOLD
AND COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION.
I JUST WANNA QUICKLY KNOW THAT
THEIR NUMBER POLICY CONCERT WE
HAVE THE BUT THE POETRY SHARED
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS. OF
INTEREST OF THIS COMMITTEE I
JUST FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON THE
FISCAL IMPACTS.
I JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT WHILE
THE BILL AND DOES ALLOW THE
DELAY OF PURCHASING
ENVIRONMENTALLY PREFERRED
PRODUCTS UNTIL IT'S ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE.
IT IS LIKELY THAT SCHOOLS MAY
BEGIN PURCHASING THESE PRODUCTS.
EVEN IF THERE IS AN ADDED COST
US ARE COMPARISON OF ECO CERTIFY
PRODUCTS COMPARED TO NON
CERTIFIED PRODUCTS CAN RANGE
FROM TO DO.
TEN PERCENT MORE AND WE BELIEVE
THESE COST INCREASES WOULD BE
REIMBURSED BY THE STATE TO THE
DISTRICT I'M NOT WAS NOT NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS. ALSO.
ECO CERTIFY PRODUCTS CAN
SOMETIMES INCREASED LABOR COSTS
THERE'S TIMES WHEN THEY DON'T
THE PRODUCTS TO WORK AS QUICKLY
AS TO ADDITIONAL PRODUCTS.
AND ALSO AND THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL THAT
SCHOOLS POST THE LETTER NOT ONLY
TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR EDUCATION
THAT ON THEIR OWN WEBSITES IF
THEY CHOOSE NOT COMPLY SO
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WASN'T
NOTED.
AND WHILE.
EIGHT THIS ISN'T REALLY THE
PURVIEW OF THE COMMITTEE I WOULD
PRE BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
MENTION THAT THIRD PARTY
CERTIFICATION CAN COST UP
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PRODUCT.
FOR MANUFACTURE.
AND TAKE UP TO TWELVE MONTHS
FOR THAT.
CERTIFICATION COME THROUGH SEPT
THINK YOU.
THINK ILL AND I'M SORRY IT WHO
WERE YOU WITH I'M SORRY I DON'T
KNOW CHARTS I REPRESENT THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION IN NUMBER
OF OUR MEMBERS MANUFACTURE THESE
CLEANING PRODUCTS TRADITIONAL
AND THE ECO CERTIFIED.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING ADAM RIGHTLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THINGS.
JULIE NOT ASK ABOUT THE HAVE THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION.
DAWN KEPT YOUNG MAN OFF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
POST.
AARON ROBERT ON BEHALF THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
DOCTOR OR TO GET QUESTIONS.
I. JUST LIKE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
THE POLICY LATER BUT I'M
SUPPORTING IT NOW.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THAT ENJOYS A MOTION AND A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
CAN I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN LIKE IT'S OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL.
WHILE WE HAVE ENOUGH FOLKS HERE
LET ME GO AHEAD WE WERE IN
SUBCOMMITTEE EARLIER WHEN WE
HEARD AB TWENTY NINETEEN BY. AND
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY TO HAVE A
MOTION.
SECOND A MUCH BY MISS KRIOS
SECOND BY MISTER QUICKEN LIKE
IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY BY MISTER
GRAYSON DRIVE A MOTION.
SO MOVED.
THE MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK A
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO THAT GETS
OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING A MISTER FLOOR VOTING
YES.
AB TWENTY TWENTY MISTER QUIRK.
YOU HAVE A MOTION. SOME OF.
I HAVE THAT MOTION BE MY MISTER
BONTA IN THE SECOND BY ME VIVAS
MISS CARILLO AND THAT GETS UP
ALTHOUGH I I APPRECIATE THE
GOODNESS.
BUT I GET OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR PEROT VOTING AYE AYE.
WE'LL GO AHEAD NOW IN ANNOUNCING
AB TWENTY FOUR OH TO LOW GETS
OUT ON AND WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING AND MISTER PROVIDING NO.
A. B. THIRTY THIRTY BY MISS
COMING AT ALL GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
WITH MISS RAY S. NOT VOTING AND
MISTER FLORA VOTING AYE.
AB TWENTY NINE.
TWENTY ONE NINETEEN BY MISTER
GLORIA GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY TWO
BY MISTER GLORIA GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT BY MISTER CHAIR GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY BY MISTER WHAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE I MISS
FRIEDMAN GETS OUT ON OF THE ROLL
CALL.
WITHOUT WE ARE CAUGHT UP IN
MISTER BONTA.
YOU.
RIGHT.
BEFORE YOU START I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT I'M HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY FROM
MISTER GIBSON'S OFFICE CAN LET
HIM KNOW THAT.
WE ARE WAITING ON HIM.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD MR BONTA.
YOU'LL BE PRESENT TEEN ON AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MEDICARE AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
ONE SIMPLY REMOVES THE TEN
PERCENT PENALTY ON NON E.
EVIDENTLY.
SECOND PAYMENTS OVER TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR CULTIVATION
EXCISE TAXES ON BOTH MEDICAL AND
I DON'T USE CANNABIS AND FOR
SALE AND USE TAXES ON A DON'T
USE CANNABIS THIS WILL
ENCOURAGE.
PAYMENTS BY I CAN WITH THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY WHO ARE
LARGELY WORKING AT IN A CASH
ONLY.
STATE AND IT WILL GENERATE MORE.
INCOME FOR OUR STATE AND AND.
ESTIMATE ARE CONNIE. THE I
THINK THE. AND ALSO SAYS
NEGLIGIBLE COSTS AND HERE WITH
ME TODAY IS AMY JENKINS
WITH THE CAT AT CALVARY CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS EMAIL JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OUT TO SAY
THAT DISCOURAGING CASH I'VE CASH
PAYMENTS. ONLY INCREASES
NONCOMPLIANCE AT A TIME WHEN WE
NEED TO ENCOURAGE OUR CAMPUS
OPERATORS TO BE PAYING THEIR
TAXES WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT WE
AS AN INDUSTRY STRONG SUPPORT SO
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
I CAN MEET ON BEHALF OF WE DOT
CANNABIS LIVING IN THE LONG
BEACH COLLECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HIGH OCTANE CAMPBELL WHO BEHALF
OF THEORY CHAIR VICE CHAIR OF
THE ON THE MONTHS PART OF BILL.
I GOOD MORNING AARON WROTE ON
BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS SHOULD BE
XIN ASSOCIATION ALSO ON
TRANSPORT BECAME.
MORNING JASON BRYDEN ME UP THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU.
LIKE TO CONCLUDE.
THIS BILL HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE FLORA VOTING.
THEY CAN MEDICARE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THINKING STUFF
THANK YOU I'M I THINK WE ARE
DOWN TO MISTER GIBSON LES MISTER
BRO. WHERE YOU GONNA PRESENT ANA
SUSPENSE?
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FOUR WILL
BE GOING TO SUSPENSE BUT WE
WILL.
HEAR FROM MR PEROT.
THINK ABOUT OF CHAIR AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY FOUR WILL SENT
MILITARY TIME BAY FROM STATE
INCOME TAX FOR VETERANS FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND RETIRED VETERANS
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF ONLY NINE
STATES BUT FULLY TAX RETIREMENT
PAY WHILE THIRTY ONE OTHERS DO
NOT TAX WILL CALL AT ALL.
ACCORDING TO DEPARTMENT OFFENSE
MOST RETIRED VETERANS ARE IN
THEIR FORTIES AND READY TO START
A SECOND CAREER. CALIFORNIA SEEN
A STEADY DECLINE RETIRED
VETERANS BECAUSE MANY OF CHOSEN
TO RESIDE. IN ANOTHER STATE.
MANY RETIRED VETERANS OF HIGH
SKILLED JOBS THAT WOULD
TRANSITION WELL IN THE
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE HOWEVER
KEEPING THE STATUS QUO WILL LOSE
OUT ON MANY DOCTORS NURSES
LAWYERS ENGINEERS POLICEMEN AND
FIREMEN.
CALIFORNIA WE STANDS TO GAIN BY
THE SANITIZING THESE VETERANS.
THEY WILL TAKE HIGH DEMAND AND
WELL PAYING JOBS.
AND PAY INCOME TAX BY HOMES PAY
PROPERTY TAX INCREASE BUSINESS
SALES TO PAY SALES TAX THE
BENEFITS GO ON.
ACCORDING TO A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND A REPORT BY
CALIFORNIA COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED OVER SEVEN BILLION IN
FEDERAL BENEFITS THERE'S A
DIRECT CORRELATION BETWEEN THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THE DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS IS REQUIRED
TO. INSERT INTO A STATE BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF VETERANS FOR
COMMUNITY CLINICS AND VETERANS
HOSPITALS.
THE OTHER ASPECT IS SUPPORTING
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S MILITARY
COUNCIL RECENTLY REPORTED THAT
STATE LEADERS SHOULD EXPLORE
APPROPRIATE WAYS TO INCENTIVIZE
VETERANS STAY IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE BENEFICIAL ECONOMIC IMPACT
OF PROVIDING A RETIRED VETERANS
WITH THIS BENEFIT AB WENTY
THREE NINETY FOR WILL ENCOURAGE
MORE RETIREES TO REMAIN HERE.
RESULTING IN A BETTER CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FREE AYE VOTE WHEN WE CONSIDER
THIS ON THE SUSPENSION FILE.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS RETIRED
REAR ADMIRAL DON WILEY WHO IS A
FAMILY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
PHYSICIAN.
THING AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FROM AYE ME TO BE HERE
TO PRESENT. AYE MYRMIDON WILEY
AS HE SAID I'M A RETIRED
ASSISTANT U. S. SURGEON GENERAL
AND VETERAN OF THE UNITED STATES
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE AND
PHYSICIAN. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY DRESSES COMMITTEE
REGARDING AB TWENTY THREE FOR
NINETY FOUR IS A MUCH NEEDED
FEDERAL MILITARY EXEMPTION. THAT
WILL ENCOURAGE ME AND MORE
RETIRED VETERANS TO STAY IN AND
RELOCATE TO CALIFORNIA.
DURING MY TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF
ACTIVE DUTY I SERVED.
SIGNED WITH THE UNITED STATES
THE INDIAN HEALTH SERVICE
STATION THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES PROVIDING CARE TO ALASKA
NATIVES AND AMERICAN MAYBE
PEOPLE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IN RESERVATIONS. AND
I WORKED AS A REGIONAL CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR IN MY FINAL POSITION.
IN THIS LATTER ROLE I PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND BECAUSE OF
THE OF SERVICES TO MULTIPLE
TRIBES LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS AND ALSO.
INTERFACE WITH DOD SISTER
SERVICES AND SERVICE MEMBERS IN
A VARIETY OF WAYS. OF NOTE MY
FATHER WAS A QUEEN WERE NAVY
VETERAN SERVING ALAMEDA NAVAL
AIR STATION HE WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN CALIFORNIA AND
RECENTLY PASSED AWAY. I GREW UP
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GRADUATE
FROM CAL BERKLEY. AND YOU SEE
SAN FRANCISCO MEDICAL RESIDENCY
PROGRAM NOW IS A RETIRED MEDICAL
OFFICER I AM A PHYSICIAN.
EDUCATOR AND ADVOCATE I BRING A
WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE TO THE KID IT TO THE
COMMUNITIES AND RICK AND
CONTRIBUTING IN RETURNING TO
CALIFORNIA.
OTHER VETERANS RETIRED AND ALSO
THEIR INDIVIDUAL IN OF THEIR
INDIVIDUAL IN OUR COLLECTIVE.
CONTRIBUTIONS APPLY.
AS PART OF MY RETIREMENT
TRANSITION I AM ENGAGE WITH
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS AND
SERVICE MEMBERS.
USING MY PUBLIC HEALTH MINISTRY
OF SKILLS I PLAN TO CONTINUE
THIS WORK AND LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO AT RISK
POPULATIONS IN PARTICULAR
VETERAN WOMEN ELDERS AND
AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKA NATIVES.
RATHER THE SOLELY FOCUSED ON THE
INITIAL FISCAL IMPACT OF LOST
REVENUE IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THAT I AND OTHER
RETIRED VETERANS PAY PROPERTY
TAXES SALES TAXES GAS TAX. AND
LOTS OF OTHER FEES.
WE DO REINVEST FINANCIAL TAX
SAVINGS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES MOST OF US HAVE
OPTIONS WHERE WE CHOOSE TO LIVE.
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WHERE I DETECT DECIDE
TO PERMANENTLY COSTS OF THE
SITE.
ANSWER IF I STAY IN CALIFORNIA.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FOUR
DOESN'T AND IF IT DOES NOT PASS
I KNOW THAT I CAN GO TO
NEIGHBORING STATES LIKE NEVADA
AND OREGON WERE TAX ADVANTAGES
ARE CRITICAL TO ME AND MY
FAMILY.
IN FACT MY FATHER MOVED IN ABOUT
A IN SEMI RETIREMENT BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA WAS TOO EXPENSIVE ANY
NEW THE TAX ADVANTAGES.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IN MANY POLICY ISSUES
PROVIDING OPTIMAL BENEFITS TO
RETIRED OF VETERANS IT'S STILL
LIKES BEHIND OTHER SERVICES IN
THOSE OPTIMAL BENEFITS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO WATCH
OTHER STATES EXEMPT MILITARY
RETIREMENT PAY VETERANS WILL
LEAVE.
SO KEY QUESTION IS WHAT WILL THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE DUE TO
KEEP ME AND OTHER RETIRED
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FOUR IS
THAT RIGHT STEP TO KEEP US HERE
AND ENTICE FUTURE VETERANS TO
COME TO CALIFORNIA AND MAKE THIS
GREAT STATE THEIR HOME. I
RESPECTFULLY ACID AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY FOUR TO PASS OFF
THE SUSPENSE FILE AND MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU. THINK YOU ARE
JUST SO SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN OF JIM
MOVIE OF NATIONAL OUR
SOLICITATION OF CALIFORNIA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WHICH
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ANDA.
URGE A VOTE I.
THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MANY SET THREE WITH
THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN THE
AMERICAN GI FORM OF CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDERS VETERANS
COUNCIL. MILITARY OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTERS IN
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OWN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ESTIMATES REVENUE LOSSES OF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY
MILLION IN NINETEEN TWENTY. AND
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS NOT
YET BEEN DETERMINED.
THANK YOU SEEN NO QUESTIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CONCLUDE
MISTER VERA THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
ALLOWING ME TO SIT TO US SPEAK
ON THE SUSPECT'S ITEM.
THE ONE THING IS THAT IF
VETERANS LEAVE IT MAYBE LOSSES
STATE BUT IF THAT ARMS LEVY NOT
ABLE TO COLLECT THAT INCOME IN
FIRST PLACE SO. I JUST ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT WE ANNOUNCEMENTS
HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT ARE
BE MADE TO SPEND FILE AT THIS
POINT.
WE'RE STILL STILL LOOKING FOR
MR GIPSON IF HE AYE DOESN'T GET
HERE FAIRLY SOON THAT WE WILL
HAVE TO CONCLUDE BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WE WILL.
I'LL LIST THE BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
MADAM.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR SEVENTEEN
SIXTY THREE SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
ONE.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHTEEN NINETY
EIGHT. NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
NINETEEN FORTY TO NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN TWENTY.
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY FORTY TO
TWENTY FORTY THREE TWENTY SIXTY.
TWENTY SEVENTY NINE TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE. TWENTY EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
OH ONE TWENTY ONE ALL SIX TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. TWENTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FIVE TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE NINETY ONE TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
TWO EIGHT TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY
FOUR. TWENTY TWO THIRTY THREE
TWENTY TWO FORTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FIFTY EIGHT.
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO
NINETY THREE TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
THREE THIRTY THREE. BETWEEN
THREE THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO. THREE THREE THIRTY
EIGHT TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE ONE THREE NINETY
FOUR. THREE THREE NINETY FIVE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
TEN. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
ONE.
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY TWO TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN NINE TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
SIX.
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE OR THREE TWENTY VITAL FIVE
TWENTY BIBLE SIX TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY.
TWENTY BY THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE FORTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY SIX TWENTY SIX EIGHT.
TWENTY SIX OH NINE TWENTY SIX
FIFTEEN TWENTY SIX EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE TWENTY
SIX SEVENTY TWO. TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SIX TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE.
TWENTY SEVEN OR SIX TWENTY SEVEN
OH SEVEN. TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT. TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
ONE TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT. TWENTY EIGHT OR TWO
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE. TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
ONE TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THREE TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY TWENTY FIFTY ONE.
TWENTY A SIXTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY ONE TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE.
TWENTY NINE OR EIGHT TWENTY NINE
OH NINE TWENTY NINE THIRTY THREE
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY NINE TWENTY NINE
NINETY EIGHT. THIRTY TEN THIRTY
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SIXTY EIGHT THIRTY SEVENTY NINE
THIRTY NINETY SEVEN. THIRTY ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN
THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE
TWENTY NINE. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
NINE THIRTY ONE FORTY TWO THIRTY
ONE FORTY SIX THIRTY ONE FIFTY
THREE. THIRTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
THIRTY TWO FIVE TWO OH SIX
THIRTY TWO EIGHTEEN. AND THIRTY
TWO TWENTY.
THANK YOU AND THAT YOU CAN SEE
THAT'S WHY WE.
APPRECIATE MEMBERS WHO DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO PRESENT
OTHER SUSPENSE BILLS
THAT WOULD TAKE.
ALL DAY AND NIGHT I'M WITH THAT
MISTER GIBSON HAS ASKED.
IN I WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO SPEAK
ON THE SUSPENSE WHILE AT AT THE
END OF THE MEETING IF THEY WANT
TO I REGISTER A POSITION.
BUT MR QUIRK HIS EYES.
WOULD MISTER GETS ANNOUNCEMENTS
COURTS ONE TO PRESENT ON HIS
BILL.
.
ARMY TWENTY NINE EIGHTY SO.
IN THIS BILL.
IF YOU HAVE CHIU LICENSED
CANNABIS BUSINESSES
IT SAYS THAT WHATEVER SAY BOTH
THE MALE OR.
FOR TO MEDICAL.
THOSE AREAS HAVE TO BE SEPARATE
HOWEVER THEY COULD SHARE SAY UP
COMMON BATHROOM.
AND SO THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE THE NON LICENSED
FACILITY SHARED.
THAT'S THE BILL I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ONLY HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AND A
SECOND BY MYSTERIOUS.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RAN MARK NOW
BEHALF OF CMT KHALIFA I'M IN
OPPOSITION ARE POLICY REASONS.
THANK YOU.
PART OF FRANCE.
SEEN NO QUESTIONS.
.
I'M GLAD THAT IS YOUR CLOTHES
AND THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISTER PARKER
PINCH HITTING.
WITH THAT IF THERE IS ANYBODY IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OUR
OPPOSITION ON WHEN THE BILLS
THAT WAS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. AND THE OTHER WAY PRESENT.
AYE. COME FORWARD TO TELL US
YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE WITH IN
YOUR POSITION ON WHAT BILL IT IS
AN ARAB TERRITORY TO CARE ON
BEHALF OF.
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WERE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF BILLS THAT HAVE
GONE TO SUSPENSE. TWO SIX EIGHT
SIX TWO SIX NINE ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT IN TWENTY THREE. FIFTEEN
THAT CAN ALL BE CONSOLIDATED
WITHIN TWENTY SEVEN FORTY WHEN
WE HOPE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE WHILE THEY'RE ON
SUSPENSE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS A WE ARE
NOW POSITIONED AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTEEN. ASIDE FROM OUR UP
POLICY CONCERNS WE ALSO DO
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL
CONSTITUTES UNFUNDED STATE
MANDATE AND IS NOT PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT MECHANISM FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
TO RECOUP THEIR.
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS
UNFORESEEN COSTS THAT WE WE DO
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
ANY MORE SPEAKERS AND SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION SUSPENSE FOUND.
BRIEFLY MADAM CHAIR RYAN SHIMMER
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
KRIOS TWO SEVEN SEVEN NINE
THANK YOU.
SEEN. NONE OTHER THAT IS THE
CONCLUSION OF ARMENIAN AND A
WHOLE THE ROLE OPEN FOR JUST A
FEW MINUTES I HEAR FROM MISS
EGGMAN.
AND SEE IF SHE BUT EVERYBODY
ELSE HAS BEEN HERE THANK YOU.
FOR COMING TODAY
.
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
CONCLUDE THE APPROPRIATIONS
HEARING